well three more victims of the
Pittsburgh synagogue massacre will be
laid to rest today thousands of people
gathered yesterday to honor the first
four victims to be buried but many other
people were in the streets of the
Squirrel Hill Hill neighborhood to
protest a visit by President Trump David
beg no is outside the Tree of Life
synagogue in Pittsburgh with the latest
David good morning beyond a good morning
you know it's been four days since the
shooting happened and the FBI is still
processing the crime scene but things
are starting to return to normal the
streets have been reopened traffic is
flowing and I have to tell you many of
the world's media have left as I look
around right now I count about four
cameras there were probably 50 yesterday
when the president arrived we estimate
more than a thousand demonstrators
gathered to protest the president during
his visit to Pittsburgh Tuesday
afternoon it's time to stop the hate
speech many of them were demanding that
the president condemn white nationalism
and toned down divisive rhetoric one man
was arrested after refusing to move in a
barricaded street outside the synagogue
mr. Trump and the first lady laid roses
and ceremonial stones to honor each of
the victims they were joined by Ivanka
Trump and son-in-law Jared Kushner both
of whom are observant Jews the president
then visited the University of
Pittsburgh Medical Center Presbyterian
to meet with for law enforcement
officers injured in Saturday's shootout
he expressed his thanks for their
service and his sorrow over their
injuries and really wanted to hear some
of their stories about the event
before the president arrived mourners
said goodbye to for the victims
including beloved brothers Cecil and
David Rosenthal and Daniel Stein the 71
year old had just become a grandfather
dr. Jerry Rabinowitz was also buried his
family says the 66 year old ran toward
the gunfire to help others Ruth Sattler
knew him for almost 40 years he would be
the kind of person who would who would
do whatever he could to help in a
situation like like that that's Jerry
he's just a wonderful person here at the
synagogue yesterday the president was
asked if he had anything to say and he
said quote sad sad very sad I hope we've
learned a lot
Gayle of all the posters being held up
around here there was one that I loved
and I know you'll love it said quote
hate cannot weaken a city of Steel David
Beck know very well said thank you very
much and we need messages like that
today